can you help me understand how I can be
having a private conversation with
someone about something I'm interested
in seeing or buying and an advertisement
for that will pop up on my Instagram
feed
I haven't searched for it I haven't
talked to anybody about it I swear I
think some but I think you guys are
listening I know you're gonna say you're
not I get this question all the time
well then tell me how it happens I got
it the other day if someone said I was
talking to my friend
yes and I didn't even have my phone near
me that was me and then I got the ad
that was me
there's two ways I can have it one is
dumb luck which can happen the second
immediately but God repeated the second
is you might be talking about something
because it's top of mind because you've
been interacting with that type of
content more recently so maybe you're
really into food and restaurants yeah
you saw a restaurant on Facebook or
Instagram you may be like the thing it's
top of mind maybe that's subconscious
and then it bubbles up later I think
this kind of happens often in a ways
that are really subtle but we don't you
don't look at your messages
you don't listen on your microphone
doing so would be super problematic from
for a lot of different reasons but I
recommend you I don't know how this
happens okay does it happen to you no
I'm sure I don't want to say no out of
I'm sure it's happened I can't think of
a good example though I get pretty good
ads though yep
yeah but but I haven't searched it I
just had a private conversation with
somebody and then it pops up right there
on my Instagram did you maybe do
something I with that restaurant in this
example online off of Facebook because
maybe there are Facebook advertiser and
then they connect to the dog no no it's
happened more than once that's why I'm
I'm just convinced I don't know how
you're doing it
mix Adam sorry I'm gonna find I don't
know how you do what's your middle name
Solomon guys I swear our list
you say no I'm gonna follow you on
Instagram and then next time that
happens you can DM me and light me up
over it and I will try to figure out
exactly what a deal